hi everyone my name is roy davis and
welcome to my talk no key no pin no
combo no problem
honing atms for fun and profit
shout out to all my homies at dc 612 in
minnesota and for anybody who wants to
get a hold of me about the content of
this presentation my contact information
is all on the screen there
before we get too far into this i've got
to say this content is provided for
educational and entertainment purposes
only
unauthorized access of other people's
atms is illegal don't do it
don't do it you're going to go to jail
secondly this presentation is not
associated with my employer in any way
except to say they've been very
supportive of this opportunity and of me
and i really appreciate that
so why atms there's several answers to
this question the first being when i was
a kid i used to go to the grocery store
with my mom and she'd walk up to this
machine once in a while and said instant
cash on the front and i thought man this
is great how do i get a piece of this
action i want instant cash
and you know a long time went by i
graduated college i got into security
and i got into pen testing
i never forgot about that childhood
dream i always wanted to learn how those
things work inside
how can they be configured or
misconfigured what does their network
traffic look like and how secure is that
vault
in my opinion cash is not going away
anytime soon
cash still provides a level of anonymity
to people who use it
that you know cards
just don't don't give you they leave a
paper trail
atms are everywhere all over the world
and increasing in numbers as you can see
uh in this chart between 2008 and 2019
about a doubling of the number of atms
um you know a lot of people think that
own these machines in in bars and
restaurants and and wherever that you
know as long as this thing keeps working
it's good right um
the low levels of security maintenance
adoption for these machines is
incredible if you think it's hard to get
pc users or you know like an infraops
team to apply patches in production
imagine trying to get bar owners to
update their atm software it's really
really
difficult um also a lot of atm security
seems to me based on obscurity and and
lack of design transparency there's you
know
missing huge amounts of documentation
try searching the internet sometime for
communications protocols or or
encryption implementations or main board
pin layouts
it's really difficult to find anything
about that
this is a document i found from 2002
discussing the triton com protocol it's
a preliminary release and it's missing a
lot of of current info
i also believe that if honest
researchers continue to expose
vulnerabilities in these devices
the increased awareness can only serve
to encourage the manufacturers of these
devices to make them more secure which
makes all of us safer in the long run
the last reason i'm interested in this
kind of research is really all of these
folks a huge shout out and thank you to
these pioneers in the atm and electronic
lock research
field they paved the way
to establishing safe harbor for atm
vulnerability research and i greatly
appreciate and have enjoyed all of their
work
i highly recommend watching these
previous presentations if you want to
learn more about things like atm history
network attacks firmware attacks power
analysis and spike attacks and malware
attacks
all of these previous uh these previous
researchers are brilliant and in my
estimation
most of it is probably beyond the
capabilities of your average criminal
today we're going to look at something a
bit more on the physical side of attacks
on atms so
our agenda here is uh
all about how i acquired my atm
we'll look at some damage uh some some
waves people damage these things trying
to get the money
some general atm info um how i became a
licensed operator and and how that went
and why i did that
um we're also going to be picking the
atm case lock uh resetting the atm
password and bypassing the electronic
vault lock and then at the end we'll
have some time for for q a
all right so what was my goal
it was a fully functioning atm in my
home
which i had complete access to it'll
process atm transactions just like in
the wild and you know i want to research
and understand the entire tax surface
including the network traffic the
internal serial coms the data stored on
the device
the vault and the cache dispensing unit
and you know so
what i have here behind me is that
device it it came true and i'm going to
tell you how that happened
these things are expensive right how did
i get this thing if you look on the
internet this thing probably four
thousand dollars new couple grand two
three thousand used
that's too much for me if i'm gonna do
some research so um things like
craigslist and ebay are your friends
i've been looking for an atm for a long
time when i found this one in 2018 this
set 100 bucks for both seemed like a
deal i quickly started researching how
they worked and what was inside them and
how to duplicate the attacks barnaby
jack had done in 2010.
one of the things i found right away
default locks on these machines are
garbage
commonly available locks and easy to
pick with a rake
also among other issues i found that the
audit logs in these atms contain a
wealth of information including full
debit card numbers and names of previous
users in clear text
and dates and months of transactions
that was supported as sort of surprising
to me
and so i got bored with these things as
time went by i really was interested in
getting my hands on an atm that ran some
flavor of windows because you know
windows
fun to hack and lots of known vaults
now this saved search had an alert that
was turned on any auction or atms for
sale in minnesota
and lo and behold i got a hit so here's
here's this auction in cambridge
minnesota about an hour and a half north
of me
and uh they were selling everything in
this restaurant and gas station
this atm was up for bid and this is all
the details i got if you've ever been on
auctions like this you know that there's
a very limited amount of information
i called the place and inquired about
the condition of the atm asking you know
what does unknown working condition mean
they had no idea you know everything is
being sold as is it's a foreclosure
auction it's all they said
i did ask if there was any money in it
just kind of joking
the replies surprised me they're very
well maybe this place got shut down with
food on the shelves drinks in the
coolers and gas in the tanks
so at this point i have no idea i think
they're just trying to get me to bid
right tell me whatever i want to hear i
bid a dollar um
now i am quite competitive when it comes
to uh auctions and i don't like to lose
so of course i won with a bid of a two
hundred and twenty dollars at the last
second
this is the first time i learned this
email i learned that i won and i also
learned there's no code for the cash box
i assume they mean the vault um
well uh what's going on here i have no
idea um
what's this thing actually worth is it
worth anything am i going to be able to
get into it does it even work who knows
so i did a little digging and found out
that first of all these machines are
like 10 times worth 10 times what i paid
for them so score but maybe not if
i can't get in
into the vault and i can't get this
thing working
well where did this thing come from um
the gas station barbecue sounded sort of
interesting here's the place
that was auctioning off everything i hit
opened in 2018 february 1st less than
two years
before
i won this auction very strange um
they're going to have dickies barbecue
if you've ever had it it's fantastic i
highly recommend it
march 18 kind of a review of the place
but uh oh just a little while later
assets 43k liabilities 1.5 million
that's probably not going to work out
long term for any business owner
things are starting to make sense here
so hop in the car hour and a half north
to cambridge and this is what the place
looked like when i got there to pick up
my atm
a lot different than opening day
i walk in and i'm at check-in and i'm
talking to the the lady there and i say
you know what happened here how did this
place go out of business so fast that
you know you couldn't get the atm pin uh
for the for the vault or the the top
and the she says as i understand it
there were some legal issues and the
lender foreclosed uh and shut the place
down
um
okay
i don't know anything about all that but
you know that's what you say so i go
back over to the atm let's get this
thing going
let's just get this thing in the jeep
and get out of here i was not
anticipating that it was going to be
literally bolted to the floor
and completely immovable
okay so i can't get into the vault to
remove the the nuts that are obviously
holding this thing down to the floor uh
it's in cement
so i call the locksmith and i said hey
you know i'm at this gas station i won
this auction um could you please come
over and help me break into this atm to
help me move it
the answer was a resounding no
no uh so
i asked the ladies you know how am i
gonna get this thing out of here what's
gonna happen this place
she said i don't care you gotta you
gotta have that thing out of here today
i don't care what you do to get it out
i said what if i have to damage the
floor no problem they're gonna bulldoze
this place at some point later i don't
care i'm just here to auction stuff off
okay
all right well i want this thing
undamaged because i want to do research
on it and afterwards i might want to use
this thing and like start a business
make some money with an atm who knows
so the only thing i can think of is go
down to home depot and rent this guy the
bosch brute turbo
up to this point i'd never used a
jackhammer in my life but how hard could
it be right i've seen it done in
cartoons
um well so i started jackhammering and
and hitting the atm a couple of times
there uh and jackhammering some more and
i'm getting a little further and and
jackhammering more
and it finally starts to to to come out
and lean a little bit uh it finally did
fall over and i removed the concrete
slab from the bottom
again with the jackhammer
for anyone wondering it takes a novice
jackhammer user roughly 40 minutes or so
to get a an atm fully extracted from a
cement floor
all right here it is out on the curb in
the jeep it goes and magically now it's
back that afternoon
in my office mission accomplished
i plugged it in booted it up and said
you know i'm staring at this thing like
okay so now what um
what do i have to do to make this thing
fully operational i want to stick my
card in this thing and have it give me
money
i have no idea i have no idea what to do
time to research
first thing i noticed when i boot this
thing up is it's running windows ce
that's pretty interesting to me what
could possibly go wrong i was looking
for a windows box
so the next thing i do is hook it up to
my local lan and run an nmap scan now uh
you'll see on the left here that i
posted the nmap scan that trey and
brenda so brenda uh
did last year uh trey uh trey graudin
cowden uh keone sorry and brenda so at
last year's defcon
so they had a lot of open ports on this
exact same model i only had 5.55 open
which
i learned from their talk is the remote
management agent
i did install the roman remote
management software and connect to it
but i did not do any sort of penetration
testing against that endpoint
it was
very intriguing and very attractive to
do that but it was not the focus of my
research at the time
trey and brenda also demonstrated an
overflow attack against uh this port uh
that allowed modification of settings
within the atm
i would love to learn more about that
and try that attack here
okay so
here is the screen uh when i boot up the
machine when i first boot it up
apologies for the terrible photo um
after booting i get this thing it says
the encrypted pin pad has gone bad i
have no idea what that means uh it needs
to be replaced i learned um error codes
97999 epp error all right what's this
going to cost me
um
so 320 bucks later i've got a
refurbished one
and things are getting a little bit
expensive
and so
at this point i've got to install an epp
in a machine that i've never really
taken apart or worked on
but at least i know how to get into
the top which we'll see here shortly
first thing i needed to do was a little
research on the inside of this machine
and along the way i kind of put together
this uh a few slides about how atms work
so before we get too far let's just take
a couple of minutes here
so there's two main categories of atms
with its distinguishing factors being
the level of security the housing
provides for the electronics and the
money
the banking features available to users
and the amount of money within the
machine itself
drive-up atms are typically associated
directly with banks and are mounted in
an external wall of a bank
especially built in closure like this
one or as a stand-alone unit
like out in a parking lot
there's really no easy access to the
money or the electronics in the front of
this machine you really have to get into
the building or get you know into the
back somehow
stealthy undetectable access takes time
knowledge and skill
or granted access as an employee
the second type of atm is the one you're
probably most familiar with and it's the
type i bought for my research
these are much less expensive and
there's far less security built into
them because they're designed to be
installed where people are present and
are working like gas stations and such
they usually are not directly associated
with any sort of bank but they're owner
operated so the gas station owner
probably owns that machine as well
it changes the threat model a little bit
here because
there's much less oversight to detect
modifications to the atm software
housing or network connection if this
thing is installed in like you know a
hotel lobby or a big long hallway at a
hotel conference center
or somewhere you know a bowling alley
maybe where there's not a lot of
supervision
as we've seen these things can be bolted
directly to the floor but many times
they're not because it's a temporary use
location or you know it's going to be a
limited time there are they move it
around a lot
or you know for for whatever reason
maybe they just can't do that they can't
bolt it to the floor
people trying to get access to the money
in these machines do a lot of damage
typically
with
various devices like blow torches
um crowbars uh this is actually the the
same machine i bought uh and in this one
this triton 9100 looks like uh
you know somebody used some sort of a
cutting tool i'm not sure
why they they chose that spot you can't
actually get to the money
going through the side there
so they were probably very disappointed
or caused more damage to the the cdu
unit in there
so during my research i see all this
damage and i'm thinking is this really
what it takes to get into one of these
things
can you do it any other way can you do
it in a way that doesn't leave obvious
evidence
maybe maybe the answer is no
i don't know
so
this one's my personal favorite because
um you know i like fourth of july so
anytime you go with explosives i'm gonna
watch um
not attracting any tension here for sure
so here we we stick the the incendiary
device in the
the output of where the cache comes out
which is an interesting choice um
and it just basically destroys the
entire top but the cache box remains
intact
so that is not a good way to try and get
into an atm
um
i would be really surprised if anyone
here had never used an atm so i'm sure
you're all familiar with these external
parts that i've highlighted here we're
going to go past this
all of the atms that you'll see
essentially have the same internal parts
and external parts
one thing you can see here is the false
door
the safe door cover
that is protected by a cylinder lock
which is typically keyed the same as the
lock that protects the electronics
behind that false door is the electronic
lock keypad and the lock bolt handle
you can see a wire coming out of the
door here that's a power cable for the
light over the cash dispensing portal on
the fault's door
all right so let's take a look inside
the vault
here we can see
the door where the the money comes out
and just below that we can see the bolt
action lever that lifts these huge teeth
that interlock with the frame to keep
the safe door shut the safe door by the
way is about 70 pounds it weighs more
than anything else on the machine
there's a look at the electric lock
inside
and there is what's called the cash
dispensing unit
mounted on the cash dispensing unit is
also a reject bin and then there is the
cache cassette
which uh plugs basically into
a slot underneath the reject pin so
we're going to take a look a closer look
at all of these different things inside
here you can see the belt driven
device that brings the money up and out
of the cash dispensing unit
all right so the next thing we're going
to look at here is the reject bin um not
very exciting but i thought you guys
might just like to look in there this is
where you know crumpled money goes
things that can't go through
the cdu
this is the back of the cdu you can see
the serial interface that goes up to the
main board and also the power supply
which also goes up to the power supply
in the main compartment
this here is the cache cassette it also
is locked with a tubular key tubular
lock
and inside we can see the
the pressure
driven
dispenser it's spring-loaded you can see
a few bills in there this is where a
thousand bills can fit
if you so desire now this same machine
that i have even though it right now is
configured with one cassette it can be
configured with three cassettes
so the the module just plugs right in
it's it's really not a big deal
giving this machine a cash capacity of
three hundred thousand dollars because
each cassette can be configured to hold
hundreds
so as we're going to see um you know you
make the call at the end of this
presentation
do you think that the locks and
everything that are protecting 300 000
you know potentially 300 000 do you
think they're adequate or or not uh
moving on to the top of the device uh
this lock is like i said usually keyed
the same as the front uh and as
mentioned can be picked um i'm showing
you there that the lock is in
indeed locked and i'm showing you there
a cylinder lock pick
so these uh these cylinder locks have
seven or eight pins this one's
particularly has eight pins so i insert
the pick and i start jiggling it back
and forth which moves the picks up into
the right position uh which moves the
pins into the right position and unlocks
the lock
so didn't take very long at all
you could also just buy this key
on ebay so if you are friend
lucky enough to get your hands on an atm
like i did for cheap
and you don't have the key here you go
go buy a key
okay
now let's have a look
inside here inside the top
not many people get to look in here i
figure to give you a look here as well
here are all the wires that go down to
the cdu
and
these come up and there's the printer
module there's the power supply uh
straight five volt power supply i
believe to the to the board and 12 volts
everywhere else
here is the receipt printer it has its
own board and a serial connection and
power cables there
all these cables come up through a
junction
right at the base of the main unit and
there we see the main board on the main
board here has an sd card a lot of dip
switches that change modes and do
various things
and we see
an hdmi cable connector and a couple of
usb ports
and then over here on the other side we
will see
all of the different serial ports that
drive the different pieces and parts of
the atm itself there's the ethernet
cable there's the modem
and the printer port and down here we
have the uh the card reader uh that's
where all the money comes out and right
below there is the electronic uh uh the
encrypting pin pad the epp
that i replaced
all right wonderful so
we see the inside and i mentioned the
ethernet port so this thing is obviously
talking to the internet and it's
obviously somehow doing transactions so
how does that work well
whether it's through a modem or through
a nick or something we get an internet
connection to the pph the the payment
processing host
um using something called the triton
protocol
and then from there we're going to go to
what's called the inter-bank network so
what is that
um
first of all the processing host
provides the connection information and
encryption keys which are configured in
the atm computer
they take a small percentage the the
processor does of the transaction fee uh
which you know is determined by the
owner and charge to the user uh for each
transaction
there's hundreds of processing uh
companies to pick from i just threw up a
few brands here
an interbank network the next step is
also known as the atm consortium or the
atm network and it's a computer network
that enables
atm cards that are issued by a financial
institution that is a member of the
network to be used in atms
uh that are
that that belong to another member of
that same atm consortium um and so the
the
way that the banking industry came up in
america it was very fragmented so there
was a lot of little mom and pop shops
and a lot of little networks everywhere
in the 2000s or 2003
by then we've had we had a consolidation
um resulting in three major interbank
networks and now about seventy percent
of the volume in the united states goes
over those three networks
uh past stocks on atm hacking have
discussed building a dummy back end for
the atm network uh for the atm to
connect to that would pretend to be the
payment processing host
but i really wanted to see what the real
thing was like so to do this i had to
become a licensed atm operator
so why did i do that well i really want
the full real experience i want to
understand exactly what does it take to
take an atm to full functioning
and and operate it after the fact after
my research is done i want to put this
thing in use
minnesota minnesota's about to legalize
weeds so maybe i'll put it at a
dispensary i don't know
um
so why do i have to be licensed well
the primary reason
these laws exist and these licenses
exist is to prevent money laundering and
funding of nefarious activities
this is really tied to the patriot act
of 2001
so you can imagine what i mean by
nefarious activities
the licensing is done through nmls or
the national multi-state licensing
system
i provide you know processor information
there's a background check i have to
fill out a bunch of paperwork i have to
show them my bank statements and let my
bank know what i'm doing
i have to pay a couple hundred bucks in
license fees and uh it takes about four
weeks or so and you're gonna do
something wrong because um you know no
matter what you do it's you're gonna do
it wrong and fill out the paperwork
wrong and you're gonna have to do it
back and forth a few times and and sit
on hold with the state and whatever but
sooner or later you will become a
licensed uh financial terminal owner
all right so i've got this thing on the
network i have my license i can connect
to the atm network the real thing
how am i going to do that well
i'm going to use a lan tap because i
want to do this very transparently and
you know not in any way that somebody
can know what i'm doing
there's no opportunity for traffic
manipulation here it's really just
sniffing and i'm sniffing my own traffic
so as i
run my own transactions with my own card
i can see what's happening
now the way a land tap works is there's
a pass-through that goes directly
through and is transparent to uh to the
the server and the client
these other two ports that you can see
are outbound from the atm so outbound
traffic which goes to my laptop and then
inbound traffic coming inbound to the
atm also goes to my
my laptop and so if i spin up wireshark
and attach to both of those those
ethernet devices i can see both right
both way traffic the problem is it's
encrypted with tls12
but the atm provides you a way to
upload your own signing certificate
which i found very interesting
if you put a self-signed cert on a usb
and stick it in to the back where we saw
before and you go to this screen
it says download search from usb
so i'm not really sure
how that all uh makes sense but
it's there all right
so we've taken a little look at the
inside we've taken a look at the network
um with the epp replaced
um i can now successfully boot the atm
and enter some data um one side note
here anytime i see a a big red thing
that says warning and then do not
uh you know do something i always uh
you know pay special attention to that
um i like to do things that i'm not
supposed to do um so this one says don't
remove the cover um bad things will
happen at some point i'm going to go
look exactly into what that bad stuff is
and see how this is implemented
it sounds like a really interesting
research project so anyway booting this
time i get this great error message says
fff fff
that means that i need to
to provide some
more setup information into
the machine
all right
so to access the admin screen
i'll do enter clear cancel one two three
all right
and so
this gives me this nice enter password
ui right
but
i don't know the password um
this is the pin i need to get to the
admin interface um i tried multiple
times to reach anyone associated with
the previous owner um still no luck
so i have no idea the pin is stored in
memory somewhere on that board i have no
idea how to get to it i don't know if
it's encrypted
it's good to note that this password is
different than the safe combination
the safe vault lock does not have any
idea that this interface or this
computer even exists they're completely
separate
this is just to get access to the admin
operator interface the default password
here is 5.555. i know that because it's
in their documentation
but unfortunately for me that didn't
work i tried and i tried and i tried and
i was up very late the ui does give you
three chances to enter the correct
password but then it'll send you back to
the start screen again and then you have
to do enter clear cancel one two three
after a few days of guessing and falling
asleep in my chair after guessing
i gave up and looked for other ways
so it turns out after a lot of googling
and reading i found that in in recent
versions of the software how song has
implemented a security feature where the
operator function passwords can be
cannot be reset to factory defaults
unless performed during a machine's
first boot after reloading the software
uh if there's any way around this i have
no idea i i couldn't find it the search
continues
all right so how does the software
reinstall work well
various versions of the atm software are
available if you search around
i found this one and downloaded it
i would love to find some older versions
of this if anybody knows where i can get
my hands on some older versions of this
uh the software for the triton 2700 ce i
would really appreciate it
um this uh this set that i found uh was
it was i think the most recent the most
recent version
and so i put it on an sd card
there's various files here if you want
to know what they do
i think brenda so talked about that in
last year's talk
i did delve into the update folder where
i found a master.zip file and opening
that is super fun there's lots of fun
stuff to play with here i'm not sure if
the bat files or some of these other
files the icons in the backgrounds
have any sort of crc
uh associated with them if there's
anything run on those if you can modify
those and put them back on this disc and
and stick it in the machine and have it
do fun stuff
that's a another research topic
altogether that i wish i had time for
and
we'll probably do in the future so
my sd card goes in this slot um i have
to push down dip switch number four
to make it boot into diagnostic mode and
this is where the computer will do all
kinds of fun stuff and read things off
the sd card
so uh pick sd card and now we're doing a
software update this takes about 10
minutes or so that's what this install
looks like and after you do that it will
reboot and now you'll get the same
screen
and we can we can reset the master
password
alright so here's how we do that
we reboot again and during the
initializing screen
we get out our old nintendo fingers and
do left right
uh clear left right
clear clear cancel clear left right
clear clear cancel
if successfully recognized the machine
will ask you
if you want to reset the master password
and then it will be set back to five
five five five five five
there's one caveat to this it's not
going to happen unless the safe door is
open
if if the safe door is not open you're
just gonna get back to the screen and so
you know at this point the safe door is
not open
um
but i need to open it i need to open it
and to complete the password reset for
the computer and i need to get into it
to see if there's any cash in there
right
i really don't want to destroy the door
in the process i've already explained
why
so the first question i have is you know
how does this computer know
the door is closed there must be a
sensor somewhere in there uh connected
to the door and connected to the main
board
i have access to the main board
i should be able to do this so
i reach for my favorite tool the
borescope
this here is a depth deck unit
5 megapixels hd resolution
rechargeable battery wireless
connectivity it's great wire is rigid
you can bend it around corners you know
and it's 50 bucks on amazon how could
you go wrong
as we'll see later in this talk i did
use this other tool
this other smaller scope called an
autoscope it's made to stick in your ear
um this has a diameter of 5.5
millimeters much smaller than than the
previous one
um it's about 50 bucks for this camera
as well so i got the scope inside the
atm during
using the corners of the cache
dispensing tray um and also that hole
where the the wire uh came up for the
the lighting of the door
um this is what i see inside uh it's the
reject bin i can see the lock the
electronic safe lock down there i can
also see some wires over far down there
um if i turn the borescope a little bit
i can see a rigid i can see the wire uh
or i can see the the the safe um
switch the the momentary switch is what
the word i was looking for uh this
momentary switch which is is connected
to the door and the door is pushing it
in and it's basically telling the
computer the door is open or closed
following this wire up away from the
momentary switch
and across uh through
some portion of the atm
it finally does surface uh through this
hole
up to where the main board is it comes
over to this junction where it's
conveniently labeled front
and then it goes on over to the board
where it's labeled cn16
so if i unplug this the question is does
it fail open or closed
well let's do an experiment to find out
i recorded this demo after i had the
vault door open and the atm was all set
up and operational but the results are
the same because
the door is closed now and the atm is
operational because the door is closed
if i pull a door sensor plug
then the computer should think that the
door is open and it should become not
operational
so
what happens is i pull out the plug and
it says the door is open the the atm is
temporarily out of service
but
it's not right we just saw the doors
closed but this is exactly what we
needed in this case so i pull out the
plug i reboot
and while initializing we do clear left
right clear clear cancel
and
we get to this screen reset master
password
reset master password click yes
all right it reboots one more time i get
here i do five five five five five five
and here i am
as an administrator
inside
the computer
all right so at least one of you was
wondering what was that qr code back
there
well it's nothing i'm not sure why
that's there it does not seem to be
something that is is alterable uh
through the configuration and it just
leads to nothing a google search i guess
i have no idea all right
so now the passwords reset i can get to
the atm inside i can configure it as i
wish but we really need to get into the
safe to make this thing fully
operational and well see what's in there
right so how well first things first
what lock is this thing
back to the boroscope for some recon
i can see the lock i can i can see some
some writing on it it turns out with a
little googling i find that all the atms
all of this particular type of atm uses
this legard lg basic electronic lock and
this is what it looks like
now in 2016 at defcon 24 floor did a
great talk about side channel attacks on
this type of lock um he he used the side
channel attack to deduce the correct
combination of this sergeant and green
leaf titan pivot wool
very similar to this to the lock that i
have the lagard basic but not exactly
the same one this uh however this
youtube video by eev blog
attempting this same attack on the guard
lock but without success so i decided to
come up with another way um to figure
out how these things work i ordered one
and
i also found out that there's another
option
which assume i assume works the same
sort of way along the same lines as
plur's attack this is called a little
black box and this device as well as
this phoenix device
um
they basically can reset the safe combo
so you take the the cord that goes from
the
uh the the uh
goes into the safe from the keypad and
you hook it up to this device it
determines what lock you have uh you
know hooked up to and then you click
reset and what it's going to do now is
some sort of an attack against the lock
itself i believe it basically guesses
every combination
in less than 15 minutes
and once it guesses the combination um i
guess somehow it resets it i i really
don't know how this thing works um you
can only buy this if you're law
enforcement or if you uh own a bank
or are a licensed locksmith so um it
costs about three thousand dollars and i
don't have that much money so i need
another way
uh so i take off the cover we see the
circuit board um if you take the circuit
board out then you can see like the lock
mechanism with the the bolt
and the rotation axis of the bolt the
main vault handle forces down and
rotates it in a clockwise direction
there is an anti-force mechanism here
there's a spring and a notch on the lock
and the bolt if you push down too hard
that notch basically engages and you
can't push anymore
if we are able to rotate that lock fully
uh
clockwise then we will pull
push that secondary bolt over into the
notch
into that linch bin now that linchpin
will stop the secondary bolt from going
over there unless we type in the correct
code which then
provides a 9 volt
dc charge to the little motor attached
to the linchpin the motor runs the
linchpin has moved and we can open the
lock all right so now we know how this
thing works
here's a close-up of the dc motor in the
linchpin
and again if we if we apply a charge uh
to the motor then it'll open so
basically all the money in this vault
300 000 potentially is protected by the
lack of voltage to this dc motor
so is there a way from the outside of
the vault to get voltage to this dc
motor without anyone knowing
or without destroying the lock or
destroying the vault or destroying the
case
let's have a look
this is a short video of the lock-in
action look in the middle of the lock
at that linchpin and you'll see after i
type in the code
the motor turns the linchpin goes up
which would allow
the bolt to turn and the lock to open
all right so here's a look at the keypad
and another interesting thought that i
had was you know there's a lot of space
inside this keypad thing that mounts on
the front
and it doesn't appear to me
just doing some some cursory research
that there's any encryption of the uh
the numbers that are pressed on the
keypad um as it's being sent into the
lock and so what you see here is a small
experiment with an arduino nano in which
i'm kidding keypad
presses on
uh um pressing on the keypad and
recording uh the key presses into a
an arduino nano and then passing that
back on out to
to the lock
very interesting research can be done
here
i believe this is a successful
man-in-the-middle attack against
against this particular lock
so yeah
moving on from that we can see that
you know i wasn't going to be able to
use that attack to get into my safe i
had to continue on
here are the power wires they pass
directly under the circuit board
on the door side of the lock so the
metal you see in this picture would be
actually against the door
and the the lock sits directly behind
this keypad
and the keypad is removable
and if we do remove the keypad
we can see through the hole where the
wire goes to the lock
that it is indeed the back of the lock
and it gives us this little nice
landmark to know exactly where on the
lock we are
because of this little silver
solid silver dowel i have no idea what
it does why it's there
but
it is there and it gives us a landmark
that little red x you see is exactly
where those wires are that we need to
get access to
all right so i need the right tool for
the job to get access to this something
i've always wanted
an electromagnetic drill press all right
so you're probably saying wait a second
this is cheating right well hear me out
hear me out
i figure if i can just get a visual on
those wires from the outside i can come
up with a way to supply current to them
and there just happens to be an existing
hole in the door from the factory that
allows you know for a different
orientation of the keypad if you want
the hole is a quarter inch in diameter
and it's exactly where i need it to be
and it's there from the factory i need
this to be a little bit bigger but not
too much i went with a half inch carbide
bit so i made the whole diameter a
quarter inch bigger all right
well i put this bit in and i get my my
drill hooked up now this drill has a a
binding capacity of about 3 000 pounds
per square inch
it's not going anywhere once you turn it
on and the the rpms of this drill is
about 1200 carbide bit
carbide tipped drill bit um really no
match for this safe door uh it really
only takes a couple of minutes to get in
there
it takes me a little bit longer because
i'm not exactly sure what the depth is
but
suffice to say i get into the lock
without damaging it in any way and now
we can see the
the wires of interest and now keep in
mind if i put the keypad back on
our mischief is fully concealed and
nobody is the wiser all right so the
last piece of the puzzle how do i get
power to these wires through this half
inch hole without breaking the lock
uh after a lot of thinking and digging
around i i figured out that there's this
tool called a puncture probe it's
exactly what i needed
this is how it works the idea you know
you retract the probe
the puncture pin you get the wire in
there and you release the pin into the
wire and
you have connectivity and you can
connect a wire down at the base of the
probe
um so this is kind of what that looks
like i built my own probes because those
plastic ones were far too big
so what i'm doing here is i've punctured
these wires on my workbench and i'm
applying a 9 volt charge to them and you
can see that it is opening
again the problem was that these were
way too big for the access port that i
had drilled and i certainly didn't want
to cheat anymore by making the hole
bigger
so i designed something smaller at the
time i used this this little piece of
wire with a hook on the end
and here you can see um
that uh you know this is what it looks
like when it's all set up i i hooked up
the 9-volt battery nothing happened i
was a little worried that my volt
battery was bad so i hooked it up to a
dc power supply uh and i gave it 17
volts just you know in case it needed a
little more extra juice
here's the full scene uh when the vault
was opened for the first time um
back in i believe the end of march early
april
and uh
yeah so you can see the the uh the scope
uh there you can see my tool
the the tool that i uh used the the
puncture probe uh you can see the the
wire tool that i created um the inside
through the boroscope and then here we
go
the door is open for the first time
and we can see inside
so
uh here's a demo of what just happened
as you can see the the lock is locked
as i push down on it and attaching the
probes and applying voltage
and
and the lock opens
i'm going to skip forward because i'm
running out a little bit running out of
time here
so we're just going to go
go past this one
to
again if i put the keypad in place
um there is no evidence of intrusion
and uh
you know as an added bonus if you want
to go the extra mile you can cover the
access hole with this half inch plastic
cover like
barely noticeable right right
all right so
again not as satisfied with the smaller
probe there must have been a way to to
do it with a smaller hole
so i started taking these probes apart i
pulled off the plastic sheathing and and
saw the probe inside
i went and grabbed a stainless steel
three mil
tube and i put a little notch in it in
the end and uh heated up the the tube to
melt into the plastic of the probe and
this is what it looks like when it's all
together
and you know it's it's a lot smaller
it's six point two mil versus two nine
uh so a lot smaller which means i can
now do this attack with a much smaller
hole
um all right some loose ends quickly
i sent door combo this letter to let
them know um some pre-disclosure
pre-talk disclosure um i never got any
response from this uh here is my email
to security at high sun america
um i never got a response to this one
either
so
i got a delivery failure notice instead
um as far as the money there was money
in the atm
um
on a trusted source advice i am not
going to tell you exactly how much it
was i will not disclose that but
there was enough to pay for the research
project and the atm and a little bit
left over
all right some follow-up research atm
wi-fi really cool i think the vault lock
man in the middle i showed atm software
modifications we talked about
um you know maybe the usd and sd card
could be fun to mess with internal
serial comms between the between the top
and the bottom right between the cdu and
the computer
you know can we capture and replay
how about epp deconstruction analysis
that warning message we saw
all of those topics i think are
fascinating and i will continue research
if anybody else wants to join me please
reach out to me
so in conclusion no key
no pin no combo
no problem
thanks for watching
have a great day and i hope you have a
fabulous defcon